this episode was made in collaboration
with re-education
if you'd like to learn more about the
specifics of mutual aid be sure to check
out their video after this
[Music]
we live in troubling times the most
powerful nation on earth is on a
collision course with complete economic
collapse
we hop from crisis to crisis every few
years and each time millions of
americans lose their jobs their homes
their health care and their livelihoods
meanwhile the rich continue to
capitalize on the suffering of the many
in the aftermath of the 2008 housing
crisis real estate companies and wealthy
individuals snapped up countless homes
of the recently evicted
and to this day they rent them out at
more and more ridiculous rates
more than a third of the entire u.s
workforce is held captive by the gig
economy
making on average 58 percent less than
other workers
and receiving no job security health
care or benefits
quality of life is going down job
satisfaction is going down
rates of depression are way up life
expectancy is on the decline
and in a country with seemingly endless
resources for wars tax cuts for the rich
and industry bailouts
we have over half a million americans
without so much as a roof over their
head
and tens of millions more on the brink
of joining them we are ramping up our
military posturing against countries
like iran and china
one to justify the endless and lucrative
war in the middle east and the other to
try to maintain global economic
domination
a position which is rapidly slipping
away in no small part due to our own
eagerness to outsource jobs for ever
greater profits
to top things off electoral politics are
more polarized than ever
the republicans adopting alarmingly
conspiratorial language and hateful
rhetoric
and the democrats as usual failing to
deliver any real meaningful reform
choosing instead to means test
incredibly popular policies into
oblivion
unsurprisingly public approval of
congress hovers around an abysmal 25
percent
with most people asserting that those
who represent us are nothing more than
out of touch
corrupt people with no interest in
actually improving anything
it's no surprise that more and more
people are looking for ways to effect
change on their own
they see that the system is leaving the
vast majority of people to suffer
and they understand that there has to be
a better way one of the most common
questions i get on my channel
is what can i do how can i help i'm
fully aware that channels like mine tend
to highlight the problems we face
without offering many real concrete
solutions
so in this episode we're going to talk
about one simple way for the average
person to improve the lives of others
build stronger communities and work
towards an eventual alternative to the
decaying economic structure under which
we all operate today
in my last video we talked about the
counterproductiveness of
hyper-individualism
this world view the idea that everyone
should pull themselves up by their
bootstraps
only look out for themselves and see
everyone else's competition is
incredibly unhealthy
both on a personal level and in regards
to building strong communities and a
happy healthy society
in a perverse bit of irony the u.s a
nation that likes to tout its strong
christian foundation
has adopted a vision of social darwinism
that is completely detached from reality
we hear the term survival of the fittest
a lot especially in regards to the
market
only the hardest workers will succeed
and everyone else will fail due to a
supposed lack of morality or strength of
will
of course this vision of survival of the
fittest is not representative of how it
works in real life
in the animal kingdom including humans
up until very recently
unity and solidarity with other members
of your species was the only way to
ensure survival
not of the individual animal but of the
species as a whole
survival was a team effort each doing
their part for the strength and
betterment of the group
it's only since the development of
global capitalism that we humans have
decided to treat each other as enemies
to be defeated rather than brothers and
sisters
if we follow hyper-individualist
thinking to its logical conclusion
we get a very dire image of the world to
come take the recent winter storms in
texas
i live in the dfw area when the snow
rolled in and people started losing
power
what happened texans rushed to the
grocery stores and picked them clean
buying more perishable goods than they
could possibly use
they flocked to lowe's and home depot
and bought up every single space heater
they could fit in their trucks
leaving their fellow texans myself
included to struggle with frozen pipes
and power outages
hotels jacked up their prices tenfold
pricing freezing people out of basic
safety
everyone looked out only for themselves
with no regard for others who also have
needs
if the people who absconded with 40
dozen eggs had just taken a moment to
think about their neighbors
there would be plenty for everyone
instead a few people took far more than
they needed and that food
food that could have fed countless
families will spoil before they can use
it
this is the problem in a nutshell a
fierce dedication to the survival of the
individual to the detriment of the
survival of the group
there is a better way in his work mutual
aid a factor of evolution
krapotkin writes in the long run the
practice of solidarity proves much more
advantageous to the species than the
development of individuals endowed with
predatory inclinations
this should be common sense if you have
a pride of lions and one of them is the
best hunter
capable of securing enough food for the
whole pride which would be more
beneficial to the survival of the group
that lion hoarding their food and
allowing the others to go hungry
or sharing their food because there's
plenty to go around a starving lion is
no good
to the pride it will be weak and
helpless a lion with enough to eat can
contribute
now imagine a vastly more intelligent
species with the capacity to produce
huge quantities of food on demand
with networks of highways railways
shipping lanes
and giant metal contraptions that can
fly supplies anywhere in the world
that species has all the tools for every
member of the species to flourish
of course we also have a desire for
profit the profit motive
is the roadblock that prevents the
hungry from getting enough to eat the
homeless from getting a roof over their
head
the sick from getting the treatment they
need every day grocery stores throw out
literal tons of perfectly good food
food which could be distributed to those
in need recently a young person working
at a doughnut shop was fired for handing
out to homeless people and firefighters
the donuts that were slated to be thrown
away
during the recent winter storm police
were stationed at dumpsters to prevent
desperate people from getting some much
needed food
here's the problem the profit motive the
thing which makes all of these heinous
practices inevitable
is not going away anytime soon we cannot
count on grocery stores or their wealthy
owners to consider the good of the group
that's where the practices of direct
action and mutual aid come in
let's take a moment to define those
terms direct action is exactly what it
sounds like
doing things directly with the explicit
purpose of improving the material
conditions of those around you
this often includes going on strike or
staging sit-ins or protests
things to bring attention to a problem
when used in relationship to mutual aid
the act of helping others and building
strong interpersonal connections
direct action could mean establishing a
community fridge or free store
a place where people who need help could
come and take the food they need
it could mean finding places for people
to stay when their power goes out during
a winter storm
at its core mutual aid is the practice
of helping others in any way you can
fully cognizant of the fact that one day
you may need help
and that hopefully the community you
helped build will be there to help you
there's an old reddit thread that sums
up the philosophy pretty well
you've probably heard the phrase today
you tomorrow me
i'll link the thread below but the gist
is this a man breaks down on the side of
the road
his tyre blown he's there for hours
watching countless people and tow truck
drivers go by
despite trying to wave them down for
help eventually a poor mexican family
pulls over the husband helps fix the
flat
and his reasoning was today you tomorrow
me
this kind soul understood that this
could have happened to anyone including
himself
and that he would have needed help in
that situation the user who posted this
story said that he now goes out of his
way to help others
and always tells them today you tomorrow
me that's what mutual aid is all about
building a community of people willing
to help each other the act of fixing a
flat tire is a pretty good summation of
the goal of direct action as well
someone has a material concern a broken
down car and the solution
is for someone who is able to fix it
politicians are notorious
for completely ignoring the material
concerns of those they're meant to serve
the one recent instance of government
direct action was the original coveted
stimulus checks
people were out of work so they weren't
being paid they needed money for bills
and food
the obvious solution was to give them
money no strings attached
no means testing the outcome is exactly
what you'd expect
people spent the money on food and bills
it allowed them to eat
to pay for their medication and to put
off eviction at least for a little while
obviously these one-time checks were
woefully insufficient and most other
developed countries handled the crisis
vastly better
but this one data point should be enough
to make it clear if people need
something
the best solution is to simply provide
it those tiny checks
while not even enough to cover rent in
many places nonetheless had a huge
impact on helping average americans
weather the crisis
of course if the past year's worth of
crises are anything to go by
we cannot expect the government to
provide relief for the people
so we need to do it ourselves now at
this point we need to make the
distinction between charity and mutual
aid
when many people hear about programs to
provide for the needy they automatically
think of it as charity
this is not always the case there are
some very important differences between
charity and solidarity
to start charity works within the
capitalist system
and does not make any attempt to
encourage structural changes
it's often done by the obscenely wealthy
or large corporations as a way to
launder their image
people like jeff bezos amass huge
fortunes through exploitation
and then donate a tiny sliver of it
often to their own shell companies as a
bit of good pr
when you see a headline about jeff bezos
donating 10 million dollars to some new
initiative
keep in mind what that represents as a
percentage of his wealth
10 million dollars more than most people
could make in 10 lifetimes
is one half of one percent of bezos
wealth
of course 10 million dollars could do a
lot of good if it actually went to
effective groups or causes
the problem is it usually doesn't and
the person making the donation gets to
write it off on their taxes which jeff
bezos doesn't seem to pay anyway
charity is all too often a scam designed
only to keep the people content with
their wealthy overlords
mutual aid helping those around you out
of a sense of solidarity
is different the goal is similar to what
charity claims to be about
that is providing the needy with the
things they need but it goes beyond that
with charity the aid normally comes with
arbitrary and restrictive red tape
you have to be from a certain area or in
a certain demographic where you have to
be employed or sober or profess a
certain faith
or any number of other lines of fine
print mutual aid does away with all that
if someone is hungry feed them if they
need a warm place to weather the storm
give them shelter no pointless
regulations no strings attached
just basic human decency and a desire to
strengthen the community
this is where we get to the important
part mutual aid seeks to build an
alternative to the current system
fortifying the community to weather the
slow implosion of capitalism
by helping your neighbors when they're
in need and inspiring others to do the
same
we can build a network of people willing
to work together to break their
dependence on aid from elected officials
who have made it abundantly clear that
they don't care about us
this is called building dual power
establishing a stable alternative to a
floundering state
handing out sandwiches is only one part
of mutual aid and building dual power
others include providing free medical
assistance communal housing
tenants unions community defense
networks workers unions and countless
other grassroots structures to inoculate
our communities from crisis or coercion
take the winter storm fallout in texas
the power grid completely failed
water treatment facilities went offline
leaving 1 in 50 americans without clean
drinking water
grocery stores were picked clean hotels
jacked up their prices to a thousand
dollars a night while people slept in
their cars to try to keep from freezing
to death
there was no aid from the state or
federal government
in fact ted cruz decided it was a good
time to take a little vacation in cancun
during the worst energy crisis in the
state's history if texas had strong
mutual aid networks
we wouldn't have had to witness
mile-long grocery store lines
or people freezing to death in their own
homes we could have organized safe
places to sleep for those without power
we could have distributed food for those
who couldn't get any we could have
helped thaw frozen pipes for our
neighbors
building dual power means working
together with your fellow human beings
and being prepared to handle crises
when people work together there's very
little we can't accomplish
it just takes a reconfiguring of our
individualist mindset
we're all in this together well you know
except wealthy politicians and oligarchs
who can fly somewhere warm the moment
they're even slightly uncomfortable
mutual aid is absolutely essential for
building a viable alternative to
capitalism
many economists even some capitalist
economists have long expressed concern
that the system is crumbling
that it has cannibalized itself to the
point of no return
whether the collapse will be swift and
cataclysmic or slow and painful
the only way we can ensure the safety of
our fellow human beings is to build dual
power
establish strong mutual aid networks and
realize that we're better together
if you're interested in getting involved
in some weather crisis mutual aid
efforts in texas
i've left a link in the description
below to learn more about the specifics
of getting started with mutual aid
i highly recommend you check out
re-education's video next
this episode wouldn't have been possible
without him and his channel is a great
resource for those looking to get
involved
and work towards building dual power if
you enjoyed this video consider dropping
a like
if you hated it a thumbs down you can
check out my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
[Music]
you